TODD PREVIS: Good
morning, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
How many of you have a
visual effects background
or are currently working
in visual effects?
Cool, nice to see so many
of you here at GCP Next.
And my name is Todd Previs.
I'm a product manager on
the media team at Google.
I've been at Google
about four years
and I work on solutions
around content creation,
so that's primarily rendering.
And we're joined
by Steve Kawasaki.
Steve is VP of Systems
Engineering at Sony Image
Works.
He's going to talk to you
about their pipelines,
their experience using
Google Cloud Platform.
And it's really all under
the guise of working
with a hybrid render farm.
As I'll talk to
you about in a bit,
we've spent a lot
of time engaging
with some of the
really large studios
throughout the world for
visual effects rendering.
And we found that all of them
have significant investment
in their on-premise resources.
So we've really
taken the approach
of how do we offer an integrated
solution within Google Cloud
Platform?
What are the best practices to
enable those studios to utilize
their existing
on-premise architecture,
first and foremost, and
then burst to Google Cloud
Platform as needed?
So obviously all
of you are here,
you're invested in
learning more about GCP,
if you're not already using it.
I don't need to go through
a lot of detail here.
But the importance of Cloud as
a business to Google is massive.
You can see the investments
we've made growing this.
I remember my first GCP Next
four years ago was down 3rd
Street, I believe that way,
much, much smaller crowd--
and as to see the business
grow, see the interest grow,
from customers and partners
all over the world--
and even within Google
to see our organization
grow has been really exciting.
I'm now a veteran in my
fourth year of Google
working on Cloud.
What I think is of
importance specifically
to note within
our cloud regions,
where we actually
have compute capacity
is our close proximity to
most of the major media
content creation
hubs in the world.
So think of the obvious places,
like London, L.A., Montreal,
Oregon for folks up in Vancouver
doing a lot of feature film
work, Sydney, Tokyo.
So all of these major hubs
where a lot of content
is created today have very
close proximity to Google Cloud
Platform data centers.
And this is useful for
a number of things.
First of all, if you're doing
low latency NFS connectivity
to mount render nodes, you can
do that in all these locations.
We literally have a customer
in Los Angeles who is using
our L.A. region for rendering.
They have a, I believe
it's 1.4 millisecond ping
from their facility in Santa
Monica to our L.A. data center.
So literally when they
spin up render nodes
it's as if those machines
are sitting in the room
next to them.
In addition, remote
workstations for artists
who are working either remotely
in those cities or at those
facilities is
something we can offer.
We work with NVIDIA
on GPU offerings.
We have a partnership
with Terdici
for PC over IP and
their remote desktops.
And actually, if you'd like
to learn more about that,
on the third-- sorry, on the
second floor of the Moscone
West here we have a complete
virtual studio set up
where we have
artists on site here.
We have artists in Los Angeles.
And everyone's
working remotely off
of workstations
running completely
in the cloud on
Google Cloud Platform.
Over the last few days
they've been putting together
a 30 second animated piece using
products like Maya and Vray
and Premier of Editorial,
courtesy of our partnership
with Bebop.
So they're putting together
this entire production
live and in real time,
utilizing an infrastructure
and resources provided by GCP.
So I think when you
take a look at this map,
take a look at the locations
where we have data centers
and understand again
the importance of media
and the media vertical to Google
Cloud Platform as a whole.
And when you talk about Google
Cloud Platform in our media
solutions--
obviously, we're going
to focus on rendering and
hybrid rendering today.
But it is important
to note that we're
looking to solve the
ecosystem problem--
or provide the
ecosystem solution
I should say, really
from glass to glass.
So all the way from your content
acquisition when you're on set,
all the way through to your
final output distribution
utilizing platforms such as
Chromecast and Daydream VR.
Imagine when you're
on set you're
collecting terabytes
and terabytes of data,
how do you get all that data
quickly up to the cloud?
I mean, we have a number
of different options.
We have something such
as partner interconnect
or private interconnect
that allows you a dedicated
connection to our network.
We also have a
transfer appliance,
a physical appliance,
where you can literally
load up to 480 terabytes
onto that and ship that to us
and get it on Google
Cloud Platform-- and all
of the solutions in between.
And obviously not all
of you are working
in all of the different stages
in the production pipeline,
but we feel as though through
our software as a service
solutions, our infrastructure,
and our partnerships
with leading providers of tools
that people are using today,
we really do aim to provide
the entire end-to-end suite
of solutions in media
and content creation
all the way through
distribution.
And of course, that's augmented
by a monetization platform,
by things we're doing with ML.
So again, in media,
it's critical to us
to offer the end-to-end
platform solutions.
Since this is a
rendering talk, I
do want to speak very
briefly about ZYNC Render.
It's something very
near and dear to me.
I've been working on
it for seven years
and was actually involved in
it before we joined Google.
It is our software as a
service, completely managed
rendering solution.
And it's really aimed at
small to medium size studios.
So what we have is
plug-ins that sit
inside most of the major
content creation applications.
And the idea is for
studios that don't
have necessarily the development
operations to set up a cloud
render farm or to manage
licensing or infrastructure
or asset synchronization--
ZYNC really takes care
of all of that for you.
It's quite an auto magical
solution we like to say.
So literally you can
be inside of Maya
using Arnold or
VRay or Renderman,
want to fire up a render, simply
click on the ZYNC plug-in.
It connects you to
Google Cloud Platform.
You can spin up to 48,000 render
nodes, complete with licensing,
all of the asset
synchronization,
and your render is taking
care of things for you.
We've been working on ZYNC
for quite a while now,
so we've tried to build
more and more complex
tools into it, in terms of
job predictability over cost,
in terms of management
for your files,
in terms of permissions
over how many users
can access which projects, how
many cores, how many resources.
So we are continuing
to develop this.
We've had some really
great progress with this.
We've had actually
an Academy Award
nominated film, which I
can't go into details yet,
actually use ZYNC for rendering.
So we feel like we've been
able to enable small to medium
studios to really leverage
the power of cloud,
even if they don't necessarily
have the development resources
that the larger
studios might have.
I think it's also important
to note how we've strengthened
our relationships with
most of the leading ISVs
out there in the content
creation space, which initially
came from some of the
ZYNC relationships.
So if you're using
ZYNC now for rendering,
you can see we support
most of the major ISVs,
so products like Maya eds Max,
Renderman, Arnold, VRay, Cinema
4D, Houdini, and Nuke
from the Foundry.
We've also been able to
expand on these relationships
with several of these partners.
In the case of KS Group,
there Vray cloud product,
which is a plug-in--
sorry, a service that
sits inside of VRay
next allowing people to
leverage cloud for rendering
is actually running on
Google Cloud Platform.
And the Foundry's
Athera Product,
which is their studio
in the cloud offering
the complete suite
of foundry tools,
as well as some additional
third party tools
is also running on GCP.
And that's a particularly
interesting product in the fact
that its again designed for
small to medium studios that
want to literally spin
up a complete workstation
environment, but
they can leverage GCP
and it's a completely
managed service.
So all the studio needs,
or all the artist needs,
is a laptop or a
desktop thin client
and they can
literally be working
with Nuke or Moto or Gatana
in a matter of moments,
all powered by GCP.
And as you'll hear from
Steve, obviously, GCP
has been working wonders
at Sony Image Works.
We've also worked with
a lot of large studios
throughout the world.
I'm sure a lot of these
names look familiar to you,
but places like
Frame Store and MPC.
Zoik Studios-- we had the CTO
of Zoik speaking a few days ago
at one of our leadership circle
events, talking about some
of the work that
they've been doing.
So the infrastructure
as a service offering
from Google Cloud Platform
and our relationship
with these really large studios
that are running exclusively
in a multiclass-- sorry,
in a hybrid environment
between on premise and cloud
is also really important to us.
And so why is hybrid rendering
important to studios and why
is it important to us?
I tried to break
it down into kind
of the reality of
what's going on today
and what we see the future as.
And I think first and
foremost, it is the reality
that all of these
studios have made
significant on-premise
investments.
And those investments are going
to stay for the next three
to five, maybe seven years,
depending on how long they want
to sweat those machines out.
But it's not a short
gain where everyone
is going to go
ahead and take all
of their on-premise
resources get rid of them
and spin everything
over to cloud.
So again, it's how do
we work with the studios
to provide a hybrid
environment that
allows them to utilize their
on-premise resources when
it's appropriate, and then
burst to cloud beyond that?
I think the reality of it
also comes down somewhat
to cost considerations
when you're
talking about really
large visual effects
animation studios that have
projects planned for 12 to 18
to 24 months and they're
running at 90%, 95% utilization.
The metrics in terms of their
cost on-premise and cloud
is probably still somewhat
slightly less expensive
to run on-premise first.
Again, but we understand that
we want to work with the studios
to help them to enable more
and more of their workload
over to GCP over time.
Anytime you've got
a large studio,
oftentimes you're talking
about multiple locations,
so having a unified pipeline
management is critical.
If you want one queuing
system that manages your
on premise resources, that
manages your cloud resources,
you want a single
machine image that you
can run on-premise
[? docorize ?] that, put that
on GCP, and not have to
manage separate versions when
you're running on-prem
versus running on cloud.
So it really does come
down to burst capacity,
and Steve's going to
share with you some stats
and data on how
Sony sees the cloud
and how they've
used us for burst.
And ultimately we do see this
as the gateway to the future.
And I'm not talking about
the next two or three
years where everyone's going
in all cloud all the time.
You know, but imagine a
future where literally you
have access to endless
compute resources
anywhere in the world, whether
it's for your remote desktops,
whether it's for
your render farm.
And think of the fact
that you can literally
spin up a studio
anywhere in the world,
whether it be for tax purposes
or for other business reasons,
and not have to invest in
set up and infrastructure.
So it's still the
very early days,
but I think we've started
to really demonstrate
the value of cloud
in working with a lot
of these large studios.
And so in terms of Google
as an infrastructure
provider for visual
effects animation
rendering, in particular,
whether we feel is strongest.
And I just want to highlight
a few of the things
at our fundamental
offering level
that studios have shared with
us is really critical in terms
of doing their rendering work.
Compute obviously, its
kind of the baseline core
when it comes to rendering.
And I want to call it the fact
that we have a set of machines
called premptable VMs or PMS
as they're mainly referred to,
and that's probably
what I'll refer
to them the rest of this talk.
These are essentially
spare capacity machines.
And these are available
at an 80% discount
of our on-demand machines.
These machines can be
taken away if capacity
is required from
another customer who's
using them at full price.
But I think for fault
tolerant workloads
it's really the
machine of choice
for people doing rendering.
One of the great
things we've seen out
of most of the major renders
out there-- again, when you're
talking about Arnold,
VRay, and Renderman--
is the fact that they all
have some sort of check
pointing or snapshotting
mechanism built in now.
So the fact is you
can set that up.
You can run a render and right
the partially completed frame
back to disc.
So in the event you're running a
machine for four or five hours,
let's say you've got
half the frame done
and that machine
is preempted, well,
if you enabled snecked
snapshotting or checkpointing,
you can simply pull up
another premptable VM
and resume the renders.
You haven't lost all of that.
So for fault tolerant
workloads, such as rendering,
we have really seen
that premptable VMs
are the machine of choice.
We also offer
custom VMs, so this
allows studios to exactly tweak
the VM size for the kind of job
they need.
You can go up to 96
cores for you your CPUs
and I believe it's over
a terabyte now for ram.
So if you're doing a very
multithreaded heavy Arnold
or VRay or Remnderman
job, you probably
want to crank to 96 cores.
If you're doing something
like a comp job in Nuke that's
not threading quite as high,
maybe 16 cores is adequate.
So we give customers and
studios the flexibility
to actually configure VM
to whatever they need.
When I say massive
size, I'm simply
talking about the scale of
our data centers worldwide.
We have a customer
called Atomic Fiction.
I've been working with them
for about seven years now.
They were actually a ZYNC
customer many years ago.
And they're called
founder Ryan Todehope
I think has a great
quote that I like
to use-- you can have
an IMX sized render
farm at one minute and a IOM
sized render farm the next.
So it's really that ability
to spin up and scale
your requirements on-demand
with literally no notice.
That I think makes cloud
and makes our capacity
quite attractive to the
large studios looking
for burst capacity.
In terms of latest
and greatest, we
do offer the Skylake machines.
And those machines can
be spun up very quickly.
So it's a very fast deployment.
You're looking at
30 seconds or so
from when you actually boot up
a VM to when it comes online.
And so along with our compute,
we now have GPUs from NVIDIA.
We have the KADs, the P100s, the
V100s that just announced P4s.
And all of these can be used
in a very flexible manner,
similar to our CPUs.
So you get bare
metal performance.
You can attach multiple GPU
accounts to any instance.
And depending on
the kind of work
you're doing-- as
I was mentioning,
we have a wide variety of GPUs.
And again, I would really
encourage any of you
who are interested in kind
of the remote workstation
visualization side of things,
just go down to two after this.
We have a nice meta
entertainment section
in the solutions area.
And you'll literally see-- we
have three or four artists now
working all remotely.
We're using NVIDIA
GPUs and Teridici
to run virtual workstations
in creating their content.
Storage is obviously
a very important part,
especially if you're not
doing an NFS mount to a data
center for close proximity.
So if you're using our Iowa data
center, for example, from L.A.
or from Vancouver,
it's important to note
we have a variety of
different storage options.
And of course, much of
the rendering software
today is legacy and does
require a POSIX interface.
So we have all sorts of things--
I'm not going to go
of the entire list.
But if you need caching there
are products that could be
[? there ?] [? that ?]
picks cache.
Cloud file storage
that recently announced
managed service for NFS Filer
and a number of other options
in there as well.
Our network-- I'm sure if you've
been to any other sessions
today or this week you've
heard our network called out.
But it is the largest
cloud network.
And it's the fiber that
we've owned and we've laid.
And we've heard certainly
from large studios that
have locations
throughout the world,
being able to pass data once
they connected to our network
is just incredibly reliable
and incredibly high speed.
So think of studios that have
offices in London, Mumbai,
Vancouver, Los Angeles that
are now delivering shows
in six to eight months when they
used to have 12 to 24 months.
The cycles to deliver
are compressing.
And the fact that you need
essentially these almost 24
hour work times to have
multiple locations working
on a single shot is something
that our network provides
great flexibility with.
And now I'm not going to
go too much into this,
but I think we're
really starting
to see some of our customers--
especially when it comes
to visual effects
content creation-- take
a deep dive in machine
learning and really want
to understand, what
sort of predictability
can I have with Cloud?
It tends to be one
of the major blockers
when you first start
engaging with the studio.
Like, well we
don't know how much
this is going to cost, how
much time it's going to take.
And what we've
seen more and more
are customers starting to look
at the data from past jobs
and try to understand and put
together models as to actually
what is the cost for
this particular shot.
What is the cost
for this time frame?
And I think as we
start to see more
and more of these solutions
around ML come online,
it's going to alleviate a
significant amount of kind
of the doubt and concern when it
comes to the unknown for cloud.
I want to wrap up and talk
a little bit about security
because it really is critical.
And we were among the
earliest cloud providers
to tackle this issue,
specifically for a feature
film, tier 1 content
I like to say.
So what we've done is work
with all of the major Hollywood
studios in terms of
working for approval
regards to allowing their
most sensitive content to be
run on GCP.
So what we do is a
quarterly audit now
with independent
security evaluators.
They're known as ISE.
And they are one of
the cloud auditors
for Disney, in particular.
And if any of you have
worked in feature film,
you know that certainly the
standards required by Disney
around cloud security,
around on-premise security
are quite high.
They are doing film--
Marvel shows, Star Wars,
multibillion dollar films
and making sure that
content is protected
throughout the
pre-release process
is really critical to them.
So what we undergo is a
quarterly audit of GCP with ISE
and that again is done
specifically for Disney.
We have a redacted audit
report that we share from ISE
with all of the major studios.
So we work through content
protection requirements
with all of those studios.
We've actually drafted a
securing rendering workloads
solution, which has been
published on our website.
And this has been approved
and vetted by these studios.
Which essentially is a
step-by-step, very prescriptive
guideline as to how you,
as a visual effects vendor,
can connect securely to
Google Cloud Platform
when you're running
your rendering workload.
So again, on top of
all the standard audits
we do across the
cloud for Google,
media entertainment security and
auditing, specifically working
with the big studios, is
really critical to us.
And what we will be working
with in the near future
is the trusted partner network.
And this is going to be
more of a formal consortium
among the major studios, among
several other major content
providers in media.
I believe it's among
the MPA and the CDSA.
And it's going to be one
standard audit that essentially
is similar to what we do now
in terms of the requirements.
But it's going to be more of
a formalized version of that,
that [? assets ?] Google
Cloud Platform can say, yes,
we've undergone this trusted
partner network audit for cloud
and now have approval
from the studios.
So that's about it
for me, right on time.
I'm going to turn over
to Steve Kowalski, who's
going to share his
thoughts on the Image Works
pipeline running on GCP.
Thanks Steve.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
STEVE KOWALSKI: OK, well, thanks
for everyone coming out today.
I'm going to apologize
up front for what
may seem like a fairly
lengthy lead in,
but I want to try and frame
the problem that we're solving
by using the Google Cloud.
And I'm going to stick
to my script on this
because there's a
lot to get through
and I want to try and
leave some time at the end
for any questions
that you might have.
And lastly, I completely forgot
about San Francisco coffee
and I had a cup of
coffee this morning,
and I'm surprised I
didn't jog to the arena
this morning because it's
really got me amped up.
So best I stick to
the script, so OK,
so my name's Steve Kowalski.
As Todd said, I run
systems engineering
for Sony Pictures Image Works.
I've been at Image Works
for about 23 years now.
And I've held just about
every technical position
within systems
engineering, all the way up
to running the group.
I have responsibility
over the entire technical
infrastructure.
And also have responsibility
at our sister company, Sony
Pictures Animation.
In addition to that, I'm a
Sony distinguished engineer.
We've been working with Google
for about eight years now.
We're GCP customers.
Were also G Suite customers.
And that's how we first came
into contact with one another.
We've been talking to Google
about rendering in the cloud
since before GCP
was even a product
offering from Google, so a
really long time at this point.
So Image Works is
a little unique
within the post-production
space in that it simultaneously
works on both visual effects
projects in full length
animated features using the
same production pipeline.
So typically you work on one
or the other, but not both.
And that's what makes us unique.
We've been in business
for over 25 years,
have worked with
all the major motion
picture studios on well over
100 projects at this point.
We're headquartered in
British Columbia in Vancouver,
have an office in Culver City,
and run a large data center
in Quincy, Washington.
At peak, we grow to
about 1,300 artists,
operate tens of thousands
of rendering cores,
and manage multiple
petabytes of storage.
So here's a high level picture
of our wide area network.
We run multiple
10 gig wave length
services that connects Seattle,
Vancouver, Quincy, and Culver
City.
We operate our own NPLS network
to provide both redundancy
and flexibility.
So you can think of
this as an NPLS cloud.
We maintain points of presence
in Vancouver, Seattle,
and Los Angeles.
And we currently peer
with Google in Seattle
to reduce the network latency
back to our Quincy data center.
We're also working
on establishing
another peering relationship
in downtown Los Angeles
so that we can take advantage
of the new Los Angeles data
center.
All our projects are
big and are fixed fee.
Our workforce tends to
be ephemeral and scales
up and down in sync with the
cyclical and seasonal nature
of our business.
By cyclical, I mean the times
of year such as this summer
and the key holiday periods
in which large [? tam ?]
[? pull ?] feature films
are typically released.
Ultimately, these seasons are
what drive our computing needs.
Recently, our schedule
has become much more
aggressive to allow filmmakers
as much flexibility as possible
to make the very best pictures.
Unfortunately, shorter
schedules means less time.
Less time means we
need more people.
And more people means
we need more resources.
Often projects allow
such little time
that the only way
to get them done
is through sheer brute force.
So many different types
of artists work on a movie
and each follow the same
basic iterative process.
An artist uses
specialized software
to create a script
of instructions
for creating an output, submits
that script to the render farm
to compute the output, and
then presents the output
to the director for feedback.
The director's feedback
informs the next cycle
until the director decides
the output is just right.
A movie is made up of
scenes, and scenes are
composed of constituent shots.
Groups of artists, each working
in different disciplines,
such as modeling, layout,
effects, layering, et cetera,
make the necessary ingredients
used to assemble our shots.
Each artist working
in each discipline
is using outputs
from other artists
to create iterations
of their own work.
For example, a downstream
artist in lighting
can't do their job
without layouts.
So inputs take it from
layout, modeling, rigging,
and animation.
This process plays out over
time until the shot's complete.
So why go to cloud?
Well for us, what had
been the typical project
is really no longer typical.
And worse, we can no
longer count on projects
to start when they should.
And more often than not, they
all run at the same time.
So let's take a look at that.
So not all artist disciplines
have the same resource
requirements.
Those who come in towards the
tail end of the process, namely
those doing color
and lighting work,
tend to have the heaviest
resource needs and the least
amount of time to
complete the work.
So from a resource
standpoint, every project
becomes back-ended.
Just how back-ended a
project becomes is influenced
by a number of variables,
including script rewrites,
character environment
changes, indecision--
you get the point.
Almost always though, the
delivery date never moves.
So any of these changes
result in more work
to complete in a
shorter amount of time,
and something has to give.
In a perfect world, you
work on multiple projects
and they time out
nicely so you get
good utilization
of your render farm
and maintain a
steady artist base.
Here we look at three features
running in the same year,
each spread out in
a manageable way.
In a world like this you can
buy the rendering cores you need
and it's a good investment.
And this is kind of what Todd
was referring to earlier.
Lately though, these
have not been so ideal
and projects are
piling up on one
another creating
hiring challenges
and being resource shortfalls.
And this is before
anything unexpected
happens on one or more
of the projects, which
is something you can
certainly count on happening.
This has become the new
normal within entertainment.
So where does the cloud come in?
Well there's really
two parts to this.
One's defensive and
the other offensive.
On the defensive side,
are resource deficits
have become so large that
traditional procurement
is simply too expensive.
These shows require upwards
of $10 million or more
and additional
resources for periods
as short as four to six weeks
in order to finish the project.
At this scale, few
companies are willing and/or
able to rent bare metal servers
for such short periods of time.
Again, we're talking
a few weeks here.
Anyone who's willing
to rent wants
to rent for multiple
years, not weeks,
and the price is
generally very expensive.
The on-demand burst
model of cloud
fits with our sporadic capacity
and flexibility requirements
without us having to
make any commitment.
Our projects change
literally from day to day.
So that flexibility is
really important to us.
Lastly with cloud, there's
no physical infrastructure
to manage, which cuts down on
the ancillary costs associated
with logistics, installation,
and ongoing operation.
On the offensive end is speed.
Looking back at the
artist cycle, the quicker
we cycle, the fewer
artists we need,
or the more work we can take in,
or the more iterations we get.
And we might even
get a better picture.
We also feel strongly that our
infrastructure should never
be the slowest link.
Its actually the one area
we have complete control.
And if can scale up resources
to save artist time,
or give our clients what
they want when they want it,
we'll gladly do so.
So why use the Google
Cloud Platform?
Well we've tried other
platforms at scale
and we've found
success using them,
but for us Google sticks
out in a few ways.
A key differentiator for us
is Google's highly performant
network and infrastructure.
Google really likes to
point this out to customers,
as Todd did earlier.
I always thought, of course
they're going to say this.
Why wouldn't they say this?
But it really wasn't until we
ran it scale and had experience
using other platforms
that we truly
understood what they meant.
And it turns out
that they were right.
Google's PVMs yams fit well
into our rendering methodology.
We launched an N1 standard
16 or an N1 standard 32
PVM per frame.
And all machines are
the same, meaning
we don't have to
take what's available
or manage complicated
bidding strategies.
We choose what we
want, when we want.
And if we ever need something
custom we request it,
and we pay a little bit more.
The Google Cloud is simple,
straightforward, and for us,
has proved to cost as
much as 50% less than
other alternatives
in the market.
Lastly, the Google team
understands our business
because the network of
support they've built
is made up of people who
come from our business.
And that's really
important to us.
So let's take a closer
look at our GCP pipeline.
Today our GCP
pipeline is modeled
to support on-demand
burst rendering.
That's it.
That's all we do.
To keep costs low,
we use only PVMs.
We cache all data using
Avere vFXT clusters.
Are instances spin up
in under 30 seconds
and are generally available
in our render queue
in under two minutes.
When we're preempted,
and we are preempted,
we checkpoint our rendering
data in under 30 seconds.
We run only Arnold renders and
typically run 16 to 32 threads.
So we're simply doing
ray tracing here.
Instances are
treated as ephemeral
with all effort
built into the image,
rather than in post-processing.
And we mostly launched
the N1 standard
16 instances, which provides 16
vCPUs and 60 gigabytes of RAM.
Now here's a diagram of
what this looks like.
Q3 servers at SPI
work in conjunction
with the provisioning system to
launch PVMs and GCP that read
and write data through
Avere virtual caches.
For management
and orchestration,
a Bastian host is
set up within GCP,
so we prevent our admins
from running G Cloud commands
on SPI machines.
Logs are sent to BigQuery so
that we can analyze use later
for billing purposes.
And a link between SPI and
GCP is a private 10 gig
interconnect with VPN.
And again, for us,
that's in Seattle.
Our first burst rendering
project was the "Emoji Movie".
We started the project on AWS,
and we finished it using GCP.
We ran for about
three weeks in GCP.
"Emoji" was the first time
we ran in the cloud at scale,
and we ended up growing much
larger than anyone had planned.
We ended up growing to be about
5x what we initially thought
we would run going into it.
So as a result we
were really unprepared
and we learned a whole
lot from that experience.
And there are really four
main takeaways for us.
First, it was very difficult
to tie the GCP auto
scaler with our
queuing system and we
made some real costly mistakes.
So we quickly took over
the necessary orchestration
to scale down when we
needed to, and that really
helped us curb runaway costs.
So you can imagine
going into a weekend
and your queue
clears out, and then
your host keep running
until Monday morning
and you pay for that.
So that's a costly error.
Second, we learned
that we needed
robust logging and statistics
collection so we always
knew what was
running versus what
the queue thought was running.
There were times when many more
instances were running then
were in our queue.
Again, this became costly,
so we wrote scripts
to collect data and
pull our system.
Third, it became
clear that we could
manage cloud hosts like we
manage bare metal systems.
Heavy handed routine
management simply
led to longer launch times,
increased failure, and larger
than acceptable numbers of
instances failing to make it
to our queuing system.
So despite all these challenges,
it was also abundantly clear
that this was going
to be the way forward
for all our future needs.
Using cloud on "Emoji"
literally saved the project.
We were able to double
our rendering capacity
for a period of five weeks
and increase productivity
of some artists groups
by as much as 2x,
which that was huge.
Eight months later we
were burst rendering again
to finish "Hotel
Transylvania III".
In all, we ran for
about six weeks in GCP.
"Hotel TIII" was
the first show where
we managed all orchestration
of our instances,
scaling them up and down
using our own scripts.
It's also the first
show where we strictly
enforced managing our
image, rather than
the individual instances
using Puppet and Young.
Less management translated
to quicker launch times
with less failure.
We had to keep telling
ourselves these are PVMs.
They're ephemeral.
And in the best case, they're
going to live 24 hours.
So there's no need to manage
them once they're launched.
But old habits can be
really hard to break.
This took a lot of
work on our part.
So I think there are
four main differences
that I can highlight
from "The Emoji Movie".
The first is that we use the N1
standard 16 instances versus N1
high CPU16 instances.
It turned out on this project
we needed the extra memory
and we were OK paying a
little bit more for that.
Second, no bin
packing was allowed.
We ran a single job per
instance and threaded
over all available cores.
This gave us the option
to kill the instance
once the job finished.
Again, we were aiming for a
little more efficiency here.
Third, as mentioned, we
introduced our own scripts
to scale up and
down automatically,
abandoning the GCP auto scaler.
And lastly, as I
just also mentioned,
we managed our image
rather than our instances,
reducing error, and
improving overall efficiency.
The [? our ?] experience
cloudbursting on "Hotel TIII"
turned out to be very different
from "The Emoji Movie".
We introduced a new
rendering workflow
that combined persistent
check pointing
with a custom de-noiser
to cut our frame
times by as much as 45%.
As a result, our
instance group size
would often fluctuate wildly
depending on the time of day.
And you can see peak times
for us were typically
right before lunch and
right before people
would go home at night.
And I should note
here too on this chart
that we're measuring cores.
And for us a core is
equivalent to two vCPUs.
Right?
So but here, you see a
nice sawtooth pattern.
And the queue loads
up with frames
and empties out in
a matter of hours.
I should also note
that during "Hotel T"
we no longer regulated how
quickly we scaled our instance
groups.
So you can see
clearly in the chart--
maybe you can-- at
6 PM on May 9th,
where we go from 6,000 cores to
over 20,000 cores in one move.
Those all launched
in under two minutes.
This is really,
really powerful stuff.
So here's a breakdown of where
the costs landed on a show.
Three quarters of
our total spend
was allocated directly
to processing,
and that sort of felt
about right to us.
That comports with [? maybe ?]
our traditional capital
spending on infrastructure,
so it seems right.
So today, right
now, at this moment,
we're burst rendering on a
project called "Smallfoot".
And even though we're using the
same rendering optimizations
introduced on "Hotel T",
our "Smallfoot" experience
seems more akin to
"The Emoji Movie".
That's because "Smallfoot"
has much heavier scenes
than did "Hotel Transylvania"
and the 45% efficiency gain
simply brings our frame
times into alignment
with our historical trend.
So there's one big
change, though.
The N1 standard
16th instance type
lacks sufficient memory
for about half the jobs
we wanted to run.
So we launched
another instance group
using the N1 standard
32 instance type.
We created two queue groups
and our render technicians
simply tagged the
high memory jobs
to go to the appropriate group.
But you might be thinking, why
not run a high man instance?
Well we looked at
that option and we
determine while threading
our application,
over 32 vCPUs versus 16 was
about 17% less efficient.
The cost for a high
[? mount ?] 16 VCP instance
was 25% more than a 32
vCPU standard instance.
And I think that's what's really
great about the Google Cloud--
there's always an option
to meet your specific need.
Even though we only had a few
weeks between cloud bursting
projects, we were able to
make a few improvements
since "Hotel T".
First, we introduced the
concept of unit testing.
It mandated a full scale
test for any major change
to the system.
We also learned
the hard way to not
assume that nothing had
changed between spinning down
the environment and
spinning it back up again.
Just because it worked
before, doesn't mean it's
going to work again.
So you really do need
to continually test.
Second, we refined
our queueing logic
to more quickly
onboard cloud machines.
The lag between instant
spin up and queue onboarding
for prior projects really ate
into our overall efficiency.
Now, to be fair,
on those projects,
efficiency was not
one of our main goals.
Success then was
really simply measured
by launching an instance,
getting it in the queue,
computing a frame,
and shutting it down.
If we could do that,
that was success.
And lastly, as I
mentioned, we introduced
two tiers of service--
the standard and high memory--
and created two queue
groups to dispatch jobs to.
Now here's a cloud usage
chart for "Smallfoot".
In contrast to
"Hotel Transylvania",
there's much more
even utilization
over a similar three day period.
The queue is mostly
full, and that's
because a portion of the
jobs tend to run much longer.
We also believe the queue
is doing a much better job
of dispatching new
work to instances
that were nowhere near
the 24 hour time limit
imposed on all PVMs.
The 24 hour time
limit is something
you have to manage in balance
with the risk of preemption.
The longer an instance
runs, the less chance
there is of preemption.
So if your job runs for
a short period of time,
it's in your interest to
keep using that instance up
to the point where
the timer will expire.
You need to feel this
out and act accordingly.
Initially, we wanted to compute
a frame and kill the instance.
It seemed simple
and straightforward
and felt like it would be
the most efficient thing
for us to do.
But many of our jobs would
finish in under five minutes.
So that proved to
be a poor strategy
because we increased both
our overhead and preemption.
Had our frame time's been,
say, 10 hours or more,
it may not have been
such a bad strategy. ,
Again you need to tailor your
approach to your specific
application workload.
Now because "Smallfoot's"
confidence in GCP
grew over the duration of
the project, a week ago
they doubled the
number of instances
and now keep about 15,000 to
18,000 cores busy almost 24/7.
When combined with
on-prem resources,
the total number of cores
"Smallfoot" can keep busy
is well over 50,000.
When I last checked, they were
computing 600,000 frames a day.
They'll deliver the
project sometime
in the next three weeks.
Now here's a break down of
where the costs have landed
thus far on this project.
It's not too dissimilar
from "Hotel TIII".
By percentage of
total spend, there's
slightly less network
and a little more cache
in processing.
"Hotel TIII rendered
about 40% more frames
daily than does "Smallfoot" so
this seems reasonable to me.
All right, so I'll
wrap up by sharing
what the next steps are that
we intend to take with cloud.
There are five areas I see us
focusing on in the near term.
The first one, and perhaps
even the most important,
is around socialization.
Stakeholders at all
levels within the company
need to understand
what the cloud is,
the benefits it brings to
potential business enablers,
and how it can be used to
change almost everything we do.
In the three projects
I discussed, at first
each team was very
skeptical about using cloud.
And by the end of their projects
all had become evangelists.
Our senior management,
producers, supervisors,
artists, and developers
all need to understand
how the responsible
use of cloud computing
can help the business reach
its goals quickly, efficiently,
and without any
sacrifice to quality.
Socializing cloud within the
company is very important
and something will continue to
put a lot of effort towards.
It's also important to socialize
cloud within the larger
industry so that even our
clients are educated on what
the benefits of using it are.
Efficiency-- we're
pretty efficient once we
get an instance managed
by our queuing system.
But we have some work
to do on the logic
that we use to determine whether
shutting the instance down
or dispatch another frame
when a job completes.
We're also not as
efficient as we
could be managing the full
lifecycle of the instance,
so that's another area
for us to focus on.
Orchestration-- we'd like
to orchestrate the render
environment directly
from the queuing system.
After all, the queuing system is
the thing dispatching the work
to these machines.
And we figured doing
that would allow
us to pick up as much as 10%
to 15% in overall efficiency.
Monitoring and logging--
while we do extensive logging
and statistics collection
on the jobs we run in Q3,
we want to better
understand the full picture
so that we'll
incorporate more of what
we logged to BigQuery
and Stackdriver
into our daily reporting.
I see these stats feeding
into some custom dashboard
that we can specifically
tailor to each viewer.
And then there's reach.
We'd like to extend
our rendering reach
beyond US West, which will
involve pushing some pipeline
servers into the
cloud to mitigate
the additional network latency.
Running multiple zones
reduces risk, especially
as our resource requirements
continue to grow.
A little further out,
we see other areas
we can leverage cloud to
enhance and grow our business.
And Todd was sort
of alluding to this
towards the end of his talk.
First is perhaps
the most obvious,
which would be to
expand to a full studio
pipeline in the cloud.
And I think there's four kind
of key parts to this step.
First is to expand our rendering
to include more types of jobs.
Effect simulations
and compositing
are two big areas for us.
Cloud workstations to accelerate
workflows and enable new office
locations and/or mitigate
the inevitable surges
in labor often required
to complete projects.
Dialinging in performance
on workstations
will allow us also to
pursue more real time
workflows at the desktop.
Storage-- we use cloud files
store and other third party
storage options to
migrate our data
and extend our pipeline
into the cloud.
Our pipeline is NFS based,
and our applications
require a POSIX
compliant file system.
And we don't expect that
to change anytime soon.
Lastly, there is our pipeline.
We'll migrate our middle
tier and pipeline servers
into the cloud and
re-write applications
to scale up and down, on-demand,
or run its micro services.
And a lot of these
applications have been written
and assume that
the machine is just
on 24/7 so it's difficult to
just swing these things over
to cloud.
Now, if we can enable a
full studio in the cloud,
we can add additional
office locations
when our clients and our
projects require us to do so.
We can truly become
a global company
and leveraging
Google's global network
will allow us to do it quickly
and on terms that we set.
It's really important.
There are also great
solutions to explore
around backup, disaster
recovery, and business
continuance.
Increasingly, with
the sheer amount
of data that we generate,
traditional tape backup
no longer meets our needs.
God forbid we lose a file
system on one of our servers,
our only recourse is
to try and piece it
back together again
from probably hundreds
and hundreds of tapes.
It's just not going
to happen in time.
And finally, the Google
beyond corp tools
that are available
today allow us
to set up cloud based
identity management.
These can be leveraged in
conjunction with cloud KMS
to secure the data we
move into the cloud
and implement multi-factor
authentication
on any web based application
using the identity aware
proxy service.
We use the IAP today
to extend flics,
which is a collaborative
story development
application from the Foundry, to
remote Sony Pictures animation
users.
It works great and
it mitigates the need
for cumbersome and complicated
VPM based solutions.
So that's all I've
got for you guys.
I want to thank you.
I wish you luck in
using the Google Cloud.
If you have any
questions, please
feel free to reach out to
me at this email address.
And I think we've got a
few minutes for questions
if anyone wants to come
up to the microphone
so they can get the audio.
SPEAKER: OK, thank you.
Thanks Steve.
STEVE KOWALSKI: Yeah, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]